and speaking of pride what happens when
you combine national
donut day and pry jc this where is it
right here
right here okay let's check in with
local shop wicked donuts to find out how
they're celebrating and raising
awareness this month in the most
colorful
and delicious way hey chef petty hello
hi welcome to the show you have to
introduce us to the pride donut
okay well okay the
pride donut is actually called
over the rainbow
what's that i said i love that over the
rainbow that's cute
yeah the donut is actually a rainbow if
you rip it open
okay we're ripping it open
rainbow colors in there
it's iced with uh sky
blue icing a little vanilla
out on top and a lovely little
blue chocolate blue bird
and it's filled with blueberry of course
so it's called over the rainbow
oh my gosh we this is so beautiful look
at that
it is great so where can people find
more information about wicked
as i take a bite uh sure
uh online wicked hyphen donuts.com
we're also on instagram and facebook
this is delicious thank you so much chef
petty we love what you're doing
for the community and for the lgbt lgbtq
community as well
thank you i love you guys thank you so
much bye
see you guys we'll be right back